[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARA ROBINSON: Welcome
to our session,
Opening the Doors to
Machine Learning--
How AAA Leverages BQML and
Google Sheets to Predict
Call Volume.
My name is Sara Robinson.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Cloud team focused
on machine learning.
You can find me on
Twitter @SRobTweets.
And later on in
the presentation,
we'll be hearing from
Dr. Chuck Brooks,
the director of data strategy
at AAA's Auto Club Group.
And we'll also hear from Matt
Powers, a senior consultant
at Maven Wave.
Maven Wave helped AAA
implement their solution.
Just a reminder that we are
using Dory Q&A for the session.
So if you have questions that
come up as we're talking,
just open up your Next app,
add a question in the Dory,
and we will do our best
to answer it at the end.
So what we're
going to cover, I'm
going to give a product
overview of BQML and Apps
Script, which were both
used in AAA's use case.
Chuck is going to talk about
what AAA's Auto Club Group does
and how they're using
BigQuery machine learning.
And then Matt is going to
do an end-to-end live demo
of AAA's use case.
Before we dive into
BigQuery machine learning,
let's talk a little bit
about what BigQuery is.
So BigQuery is our Cloud
data analytics warehouse.
It lets you store and query lots
and lots of data super fast.
What do we mean by lots of data?
Petabyte-scale
storage and queries.
And you can do it
all in familiar SQL.
The great thing about BigQuery
is that it's fully managed
and serverless.
So you don't have to
worry about spinning up
any of the infrastructure
to run complex queries.
BigQuery will handle
all of that for you.
So BigQuery is a
great starting point
for machine learning because
you often need a lot of data
to get started with
machine learning.
But if you haven't ever built a
machine learning model before,
that process can be daunting.
There's a lot to learn.
It's also expensive
for companies
to hire enough data scientists
to build these machine learning
models.
And it's complex and time
consuming to take your data out
of a data warehouse, like
BigQuery, and feed it
into your machine
learning pipeline.
So let's talk about
the process of how
we would build a custom machine
learning model without BQML.
We would first
identify a problem
that we would want to
solve with machine learning
and gather our data.
Then we'd preprocess
our data, so we'd
want to get it into the right
format for our machine learning
models.
So this means if we
had categorical data,
we would need to one-hot
encode that into arrays.
Then we would split our data.
So an important concept
in machine learning
is train/test split.
So you take about
80% of your data, use
that to train your model,
and you set aside about 20%
for testing to see how
your model performs on data
that it's never seen before.
Then in step four,
you're actually
writing the code to
build your model,
choosing your
model architecture,
and training and
evaluating your model.
You might repeat steps four
and five a couple of times
until you get accuracy
that you're happy with.
Then finally, you'll need
to spin up infrastructure
to deploy your model so that
you can handle prediction
requests from your users.
The great thing about BQML is
that it simplifies this a lot.
So with BQML, all you need
to do is identify a problem
that you want to solve
with machine learning,
gather your data,
write a query to train
and evaluate your model.
And then it's automatically
available to get predictions.
So just to summarize some
really great features of BQML,
it lets you execute ML
models without moving
your data from BigQuery.
So you don't have to take your
data out of the data warehouse
and feed it into
your ML pipeline.
You can do it all
right from BigQuery.
You can iterate on
your models and SQL.
So it's really fast
to train new models,
try out different sets
of features and labels.
And BQML also
automates common tasks
like hyperparameter tuning
and train/test split,
which I talked about before.
So this is all of
the SQL code you need
to build and train your model.
In this example,
we're building a model
to predict how many
bikes are in circulation
in New York given some data
on the weather for that day.
So we tell it the type
of model we want to use,
the labels that we're
using for the model.
And then we tell it what
table to grab the data from.
And once this query
finishes, we've
got a trained model ready to go.
Similarly, to
generate predictions,
you just call ML.PREDICT.
And when you run
this, BQML will add
a column called predicted
underscore and then whatever
your label name column name was.
So there's some really
awesome new and upcoming
features in BQML that
I want to highlight.
Model evaluation charts are
now available in the UI.
So once your model trains, you
get a little bit more insight
into how that
training process went
and what evaluation looks like.
K-means clustering
models are in Beta.
And then we have a
bunch of different Alpha
features here-- matrix
factorization, the ability
to import TensorFlow
models that you've already
trained externally
and query them
in BQML, feature preprocessing
functions, and TensorFlow DNN
Classifier and DNN
Regressor models.
So if you want to
try any of these out,
talk to your sales reps.
Or reach out to me,
and I can connect you
to the right people.
Just send me a DM on
Twitter @SRobTweets.
So I never like to get too
far into a presentation
without showing some demos.
So we're going to
see some demos of two
different types of BQML models.
The first will be
a regression model.
Regression model just
means that our model is
predicting a numerical value.
So we're going to see,
given the weather,
how many New York City
Citibikes are in circulation.
And then for our
classification model,
I've got some data on
different types of candy bars
because everyone loves candy.
And we're going to see, given
some data on a candy bar,
is it chocolate or not?
So let's go to the demo.
So this is the BigQuery UI.
Make it a little bit bigger.
There we go.
I've got some
saved queries here.
So the first query I'm going
to run is a prediction query,
and this is on my bike model.
And so what this
is going to do is
it's going to query
my bike model.
And I've got a test table here
with, I believe, just four
examples of data that wasn't
included in our training set.
And we'll see if our model
can get close to predicting
the actual number of trips.
So this is what the query looks
like, very similar to what
you saw on the slide.
And I'm going to run that.
And it's done, and we can now
compare predicted num trips
with actual number of trips.
And we can see that
it's pretty close here.
So we get 20,000,
20,000, 12,000, 12,000.
All those predictions
are looking pretty good.
So that was a prediction
for a regression model.
Now I'm going to show a
prediction for our chocolate
classification model.
So let's take a
look at the data.
Here's our test data.
And what this model
is going to predict
is whether or not
it's chocolate.
So 0 for not chocolate,
1 for chocolate.
And so when we run
this query, we'll
see that the output is a
little bit different than what
we get in the regression model.
So this is telling us the
predicted class for each input.
But we also get data
on the probability
that the particular input
belongs to this class.
So what this is telling us
is that there is a 97% chance
that this is a
chocolate candy bar
and then 3% chance
that it's not.
Similarly for this
one, we get 93%.
And then these two, it predicted
both of these correctly
as chocolate.
So we get 99% confidence
for this one and nearly 98%
confidence for that one.
So that is how you generate
predictions on models in BQML.
But I also want to
show you how easy it is
to train a new model in BQML.
So I want to show
you the query that we
use to train that chocolate
classification model.
And I'm actually going to
change this a little bit.
So this was a
classification problem.
We're going to change this
to a regression problem.
So another item
from our data set
is the popularity of each
candy bar as a percentage.
In the data set, it's
called winpercent.
So we're going to change this.
And all we need to do to
change it to a regression model
is change this model type
to linear regression.
We now need to
collect our new label
column, which is winpercent.
And then we will change
the labels to that.
So I'm going to kick this off.
It should take about
a minute to run.
But again, the great thing
about what BQML is doing here
is it's making this whole
process a lot simpler.
So it used to take
weeks or maybe even
months of doing all these
steps of collecting your data,
getting it into
the right format,
converting categorical
data to arrays.
Under the hood BQML is taking
care of all that for you.
So when our model
finishes, we should
be able to run a query very
similar to the bike regression
query that we saw here.
And you saw how easy it is to
develop models iteratively.
So if I wanted to
add new features,
maybe switch my label,
it's just a matter
of changing a
couple lines of SQL.
I don't need to rebuild my
model code from scratch.
So BQML really simplifying
a lot of these steps for us.
And again, the query should
finish in about a minute.
There we go.
So our model's created.
We will go to our
model, and we can
see that this is what our
model schema looks like.
So we'll get this
predicted winpercent value.
And if we go back to
our Saved queries,
we will just modify
this query slightly
to query from our new
model, which we called
chocolate_percent.
And we'll add the
winpercentage field to it, too.
So we'll run this query
and see how our model does
at predicting candy popularity.
So here we get the
predicted percentage of 42.
If we scroll over here,
the actual was 39.
We can compare the
rest of them, 39, 35.
And it looks pretty close across
the board for our predicted
and our actual.
So there you can
see how simple it
is to generate predictions and
also train new models in BQML.
So if we could go
back to the slides.
So there's an endless
number of possibilities
of different model types
that you could build
in BigQuery machine learning.
I'm not going to go into
all of these on this slide,
but you get the idea of
how you could apply it
across many
different industries.
And the other product that AAA
used in their implementation
is Apps Script and
what is Apps Script?
Apps Script is a serverless
JavaScript runtime
for G Suite automation.
So it lets you
really easily connect
different Google products.
It's entirely serverless.
So the Code Editor
lives in your browser,
but the scripts run
on Google servers.
It's written in a language
based on JavaScript.
So if you know
JavaScript, you're
good to go getting
started with Apps Script.
And it lets you automate
tasks across different Google
products.
I really like this
code snippet example.
So what this is doing
is in the first row
we're getting a row from
a spreadsheet, which
is an address.
Then we're creating a
static map of that address
and then emailing
that map to somebody.
So in just five
lines of code, we
connect Google Sheets,
Google Maps, and Gmail.
And you can also
connect additional APIs
using Apps Script through
what's called advanced Google
services.
So this is what we'll use to
connect BigQuery in the demo
from Matt that
you'll see later on.
So using the advanced
services, you
don't have to worry at
all about authentication.
So it's just as if you were
using the regular BigQuery
client library in
your Apps Script code.
G Suite Add-ons allow
developers to build
many applications that live
alongside top G Suite apps.
They're installable domain-wide.
And we use Add-ons in
the demo that you'll
see shortly to embed
a tool within Google
Sheets as a sidebar.
So just to summarize
the different use cases
that we've seen
with BQML so far,
we've seen customers use BQML
to simplify existing workflows.
So take existing machine
learning pipelines,
custom pipelines, and then
move those over to be BQML.
We've also seen BQML
as a great entry point
to machine learning.
So for data analysts
that might not
have experience with
ML and their data
is already in
BigQuery, they can just
write some SQL queries to
get started training custom
machine learning models.
And then we've also seen it
used to complement existing
machine learning workflows.
So let's say you have a custom
machine learning pipeline,
but you've got a new idea.
And you want to
test it out to see
if it'll work, to see if
there's a relationship
between a specific set
of features and labels.
So we've seen a bunch of
customers using BQML so far.
And I'm really
excited to introduce
Dr. Chuck Brooks, the director
of data strategy at AAA's Auto
Club Group, to tell us
more about their use case.
Take it away, Chuck.
CHUCK BROOKS: Thank you, Sara.
I am Dr. Chuck Brooks, and I
am from the Auto Club Group.
How many folks know of AAA?
Oh, yeah.
How many AAA members do we have?
Even better.
That's what I'm talking about.
OK.
So for you that know
about us, you probably
know about our
roadside services.
Certainly, if
you're a member, you
know about our
roadside services.
It's pretty common
service that we offer.
But perhaps you didn't
know that we really
have 12 lines of business.
And many of them have
nothing to do with roadside.
So we offer a full
travel agency.
Perhaps you didn't know that we
have a full bank, that we offer
life insurance and full
line of insurance products,
including home and auto.
In many of the states that we
service, we do car repairs.
So automotive repair
services as well.
What do these all
have in common?
Well, for us, it's all
about the customer.
It's all about offering
services to our customer
that enrich their experience
and their lives and the things
that they have to do every day.
It's all about handling
those tough situations.
I mean, when your car is broken
down on the side of the road,
or you get up in the morning
and you go out to start the car
and it doesn't start,
you need some help.
And we want to be there for you.
So when our customers
call, it's important
that we be there to
answer the phone.
Of course, we're doing digital
transformation like many folks.
And you can do a lot more on
your phone, or with a text,
or on our mobile app.
But when you reach out, we
need to be there for you.
And so when I joined Triple AAA
just some short 10 months ago,
we needed to bring
the data together
from all of those
lines of business.
Like many companies, our
data was siloed inside
of each one of the
lines of business.
And in fact, the different
lines of business and the data
there couldn't
talk to each other.
Have you experienced that
before in your organizations?
Would you be surprised
if I told you
that the banking customers,
the banking organization
didn't know who our 10
million members were?
I was, and I've seen this.
I've been doing this
for almost 40 years.
And I've seen silos of
data, but we had taken it
to a whole new level.
So we began to
build a data lake.
And we began to use GCP products
to do that, primarily BigQuery,
but the rest of the
data stores as well.
And we began to
move our data in,
and we began to integrate it.
And we began to
put it in formats
where it was usable where
analysts could look at it.
And they could
understand what was
happening across organization.
But as we did that, one of
the things that I noticed
was that we hadn't made
it easy for analysts
who weren't SQL developers to
necessarily get to that data.
And so I looked across
the GCP platform.
And I said, well,
what can we use?
What tools can we
bring into play
that allow analysts who
not aren't necessarily
SQL developers to be more
effective in our environment?
And I thought, BigQuery, Google
Sheets, because everybody
knows spreadsheets.
Analysts love spreadsheets.
And BQML.
And I said, how can we
bring these together
to begin to predict how many
call center agents we need
to have available
at any given time
so that when our customers
call, we can be there?
And so I reached out to one
of our trusted partners.
I hope you guys know the
folks from Maven Wave.
We work with them regularly.
They do some great work with us.
They don't try to
do the work for us.
They like to work with us.
And if you're working
with partners,
you know how important that is.
So let me introduce Matt.
And Matt can show you a little
bit about the application
that we've created.
It's been sanitized a little
bit, but you'll get the idea.
MATT POWERS: Oh, thank
you, Dr. Chuck Brooks.
That was a great intro.
So yeah, Maven Wave is a
Google Premier Partner.
On the right-hand
side here, we've
got the different ways that
Maven Wave's broken down
to its different practices.
And it's actually
pretty closely aligned
with the different Google
products that are out there.
So Data Analytics,
something I'll
be focusing on today,
things like BigQuery ML
and all the other great machine
learning tools and capabilities
that Google has, and everything
from enterprise collaboration.
So helping companies integrate
G Suite into their environments.
So again, thank you,
Dr. Chuck Brooks.
So now focusing on the problem.
So as Chuck mentioned,
being able to answer
the call at the different call
centers is crucial to AAA.
Being there when
someone calls when
they're in an accident
or their vehicle--
a flat tire, whatever
it may be, they
need to be there
to answer the call.
So that was really
crucial for this use case.
So we've got some of the KPIs
for AAA call centers, things
like the customer
experience, the agent
utilization, the cost.
And all of these things
can be tied back to,
is an agent in the call center?
Do they have the right
staff for this call center?
So with that in
mind, the problem
that we're trying
to solve is, how
can we always make sure that
someone is there in the call
center to answer the call?
So with that being the
problem, what was the solution?
And Chuck and Sara
have both hit on this.
But we wanted to
make it very easily
to run a lot of
different scenarios,
to be able to predict what that
call demand was going to be.
So we built a model using
BQML, as Sara walked through.
We then wanted to expose
the model to users
throughout the organization
in a very easy to use way.
And we did that through Google
Sheets and the Google Sheets
Add-on.
And again, by doing this,
it's allowed users with little
to no ML experience
to really utilize
the power of machine
learning to run
these different
what-if scenarios.
So the end result before
we jump into the demo
here, so we created
a BQML model.
We integrated that
into Google Sheets.
And then that integration was
possible through Apps Script.
Other last note here is it was
two weeks of development time.
So these tools, because we're
using both GCP and G Suite,
the integration
between these two
was fairly simple
and pretty quick
development time to get to a
good minimum viable product.
So with that, I'd like
to turn over a demo.
Great.
So what have we here?
We've got a Google Sheet.
Most people are
going to be familiar.
Most users at AAA
are going to be
familiar with this
type of experience.
You don't need any SQL skills to
navigate your way around here.
So we've got a few
different inputs
that went into our models.
So we've got things
like state, county,
month, what's the
members segment,
because AAA doesn't
want to just predict
the call volume of a county.
They want to predict the call
volume of a specific member
segment.
We've also got things
like population
and the per capita
income during that year.
And then finally the member
count in that community
and then that member segment.
So what we've done here is we've
created two what-if scenarios.
So we've said,
what if per capita
goes up for the
Florida Bay County?
And then the second
one we looked at,
what if the member
count increases
by 10% every single year?
How is that going to change
the call volume for that call
center?
And then from that, what
sort of hiring decisions
does AAA need to make in
order to staff that properly?
So we've got or two
what-if scenarios.
And what I've done up here is
just, as Sara was mentioning,
this is a Google Sheets Add-on.
So again, this was created all
through Google Apps Script.
What I'll do is
I'll highlight all
of the things that go into
the models, so the xrange.
And then I'll tell BQML where
I want the output to display.
So I hit run model there.
And what it did
behind the scenes
is we created a model
in BQML, and then we're
now surfacing the results.
So we gave it the input
data, and now we're
surfacing the results
in column I here.
So we can see that for the first
scenario, as per capita income
goes up, it looks like
there, the predicted call
volume will go up slightly.
The next one, if
the member count
increases by 10%
every year, there
will be some substantial
growth in the predicted call
volume for AAA.
So that at a high
level is the demo.
And it's just highlighting all
the different what-if scenarios
that an analyst can now play.
They can change the
state, change this county,
change a member segment.
What happens if the
population decreases?
So a bunch of what-if
scenarios that can
be utilized by anyone in AAA.
So now, I'm jumping
back to slides.
So a few more.
Diving a little bit deeper into
what problem does this solve,
and how does this help AAA?
So machine learning is becoming
easier and easier to use.
Now that you've opened
up to spreadsheets,
the users that have the ability
to interact with spreadsheet
is obviously greater than the
users that have SQL skills
or even specific machine
learning Python skills.
So greater adoption
is definitely possible
using something like this
through Google Sheet.
Now talking about the
model delivery cycle.
So here's the
typical ML process.
You start with a
business objective.
And then all the things
highlighted in blue
are areas where BQML can really
help you with the full model
lifecycle process.
The first two there,
the exploring and data
selection and then
the preprocessing,
most of time in machine
learning work, that's
70% of the challenge and 70%
of where the time's spent,
is getting the right amount
of data, getting enough of it,
making sure you do that
exploratory data analysis,
you find what features
are important,
and then the preprocessing.
So BQML can't solve
all these problems,
but it does do a few key things
to help you with this process.
So the explore and
data selection.
So in the example I just
showed, per capita income
and population, I was
actually able to get that
through BigQuery's
public data sets.
They've curated great
public data sets, everything
from census data
to weather data,
all sorts of great information.
And the ability to
join that open source
data set into your model
is just a SQL join.
You don't need to go out and
buy any sort of data set.
It's just a SQL join.
So that was the first thing.
As far as the
exploration, it was all
done through a SQL interface,
which is fairly easy.
And then they've
also got a bunch
of other great tools, things
like Dataprep and Data Studio,
to do that data visualization
and that exploratory data
analysis which is so important
for machine learning problems.
Then the preprocessing.
So some great things
that it handles
behind the scenes for you.
So one-hot encoding.
So for those of you who are
familiar with machine learning,
if you have any categorical
features like the state
or the county, then
you need to convert
that into some array, as
Sara was talking about,
so essentially
rows of 0s and 1s.
That's all done for you
automatically behind the scenes
with BigQuery.
So it can handle
categorical features.
And then it handles
missing data.
So if you have any
missing data, there's
ways that you can set how
you want it to handle it.
But out of the box, it'll
put the median value in there
for you.
So it won't solve all the
preprocessing and data
selection steps, but there's
a lot of great things
that make that process easier
in the Google ecosystem
and with BQML.
And then the rest of the cycle,
BQML can handle a lot of this.
So model selection Sara hit on.
They're coming out with more
and more models every day.
And then the train, evaluate,
tune, predict, and serve,
that is all done through BQML.
So now we've created this model.
We've exposed it
in Google Sheets.
How do you actually deploy
this in an organization?
And that's what this
slide is getting at here.
So we've got our data
scientists and data analysts
building these models in BQML.
They've built model A, B, and
C for predicting call volume,
predicting where
accidents are going
to happen, all these different
things that you can predict.
Now I want to expose
this to the organization.
So we have the Google
Sheet on the right.
And really, the
only thing you need
to do to expose that model
to your organization is you
need to give a user who
wants to use a model
access to the underlying
data set and the model
inside of BigQuery.
So it's as simple as
provisioning a user access
to that model and that data set.
And then users throughout the
organization can utilize this.
The last step in the areas that
we know as AAA to the Maven
Wave partnership we
need to grow this
is giving users better
insights into how
the model's performing.
So we're just giving
them the output.
But what's the accuracy?
Give users the
confidence interval
that the predicted call volume
is going to be between x and y.
So instead of just giving
them a black box here's
the answer, giving
them more insight into,
how accurate is this?
So it's not just used blindly.
So that's an area that we're
working on and figuring out
the best way to
expose that to users
who, again, aren't as familiar
with BigQuery machine learning.
So with that, I'm
going to turn it over
to Chuck to talk about
some of the value
they've seen so far with AAA.
CHUCK BROOKS: Thanks, Matt.
So was that cool?
Is that cool stuff?
I mean, these guys do a
great job of presenting that.
That's great stuff, right?
Let me ask you,
do you think folks
in your organization,
analysts in your organization,
can use these tools?
Probably?
Yeah?
OK, good.
Look, we've got 3,000 agents
across five call centers
handling over 15
million calls a year.
And I got to tell you that
this is working for us.
Early MVP results
show that we can
begin to reduce call times
because we're accurately
able to put the right staff
in place on a regular basis.
Now, that's huge for us
for all of the reasons
that I mentioned.
When our customers call,
we need to be there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]